this video we're going to try to get a
sense of what the limit as X approaches
3 of X to the 3rd minus 3 x squared over
5 X minus 15 is and when I say get a
sense we're gonna do that by seeing what
values for this expression we get as X
gets closer and closer to 3 now one
thing that you might want to try out is
well what happens to this expression
when X is equal to 3 well then it's
going to be 3 to the third power minus 3
times 3 squared over 5 times 3 minus 15
so it x equals 3 this expression is
going to be in the C in the numerator e
of 27 minus 27 0 over 15 minus 15 over 0
so this expression is actually not
defined at x equals 3 we get this
indeterminate form we get 0 over 0 but
let's see even though the function even
though the expression is not defined
let's see if we can get a sense of what
the limit might be and to do that I'm
gonna set up a table so let me set up a
table here and actually I want to set up
two tables so this is X and this is X to
the 3rd minus 3x squared over 5x minus
15 and actually I'm gonna do that again
and I'll tell you why in a second so
this is gonna be X and this is X to the
3rd minus 3x squared over 5x minus 15
the reason why I set up two tables I
didn't have to do two tables I could
have done it all in one table but
hopefully this will make it a little bit
more intuitive what I'm trying to do is
on this left table I'm gonna let's try
out X values that get closer and closer
to 3 from the left from values that are
less than 3 so for example we go to 2
point 9 and figure out what the
expression equals when X is 2.9 but then
we could try to get even a little bit
closer than that we could go to 2 point
9 9 and then we could go even closer
than that we could go to 2 point 9 9 9
and so one way to think about it here is
we try to figure out what this
expression equals as we get closer and
closer to three we're trying to
approximate the limit from the left so
limit from the left and why do I say the
left well if you think about this on a
coordinate plane these are the X values
that are to the left of three but we're
getting closer and closer and closer
we're moving to the right but these are
the X values that are on the left side
of three they're less than three but we
also in order for the limit to exist we
have to be approaching the same thing
from both sides from both the left and
the right so we could also try to
approximate the limit from the right and
so what values would those be well those
would be those would be X values larger
than three so we could say three point
one but then we might wanna get a little
bit closer we could go three point zero
one but then we might want to get even
closer to three three point zero zero
one and every time we get closer and
closer so we're gonna get a better
approximation for or we're gonna get a
better sense of what we are actually
approaching so let's get a calculator
out and do this and you could keep going
two point nine nine nine nine nine nine
three point zero zero zero zero zero one
now one key idea here to point out
before I even calculate what these are
going to be sometimes when people say
the limit from both sides or the limit
from the left or the limit from the
right they imagined that the limit from
the left is negative values and the
limit from the right are positive values
but as you can see here the limit from
the left are to the left of the x value
that you're trying to find the limit at
so these aren't negative values these
are just approaching the three right
over here from values less than three
this is approaching the three from
values larger than three so now let's
fill out this table and I'm speeding up
my work so that you don't have to sit
through me typing everything into a
calculator
so based on what we're seeing here I
would make the estimate that this looks
like it's approaching 1.8 so is this
equal to 1.8 as I said in the future
we're going to be able to find this out
exactly but if you're not sure about
this you could try even closer and
closer and closer values